you
when working with 13 days and like
$8,000 you are talking about just a few
hundred dollars a day that you have for
for everything you're doing and so
you're you're not you don't have time to
like do pickups you don't have time to
you know try to set up a shot once you
get there you need to make sure you know
exactly what you're going to be doing
that day so when we got to when I got to
finishing the script you know I'm an
illustrator that's what I did for a long
time comic books and children's books
and I did storyboards for movies and I I
saw the importance of getting the
storyboards down so that you when you
get to to the set you're not wasting
time
so I storyboarded the entire script from
you know the very first shot to the very
last shot and I knew it was gonna be
important but I didn't realize how
important it was till once we got there
so my first ad REM Mikan Berg was able
to open up the book look at the shot we
needed and say we need this shot and we
go okay let's set up the shot Dan RDP
set shot up sets lights up shoots it we
really do a red circle around that
what's the next shot here's the next
shot right here right in front of us
because we have the storyboards scripted
I mean Illustrated and that was far and
above a huge important piece of the
puzzle to get the movie done in time on
budget and and finished without having
to go back and go oh we we totally
forgot this shot and now we have to find
the location again and find the actors
again and set up this time we didn't
have to do that because we looked at the
script we looked at the storyboards we
had finished it all and I didn't expect
to walk into the first meeting of the
film and immediately know what the film
was gonna look like in the end which was
very important and now that I'm editing
the film
I don't really know what I would have
done without it because every time I go
into a scene the first thing I do is I
look at all the storyboards to get a
feeling for what Joe wants out of the
scene and knowing that having that
backbone that structure allows me to
kind of branch off of it and to build
off of it and to be more creative
because I can allocate more of my mind
and more of my time to to the little
details as opposed to the backbone
structure I think the storyboards are
one of the most important parts of
making sure this film got made on time I
mean we shot 90 pages in 13 days which
was kind of insane and I just remember
the first time we had that or we were
presented with storyboards I looked at
this and said this is gonna make my job
a million times easier I mean the movie
was basically already made and all all
we had to do was just get in there and
actually shoot it and even though we did
change up a few things here there at
least we still had the foundation of
everything already built so I was able
to see exactly what Joe wanted to make
and that made everybody's life a hundred
times easier
you